simon dew is a computer science
at washington university he comes by way
of
cmu where he got his phd and then
institute for advanced studies at
princeton
where he was a postdoc and then he's
been to every high-tech
lab there is so welcome to the program
we look forward to hearing your work
thanks for an introduction so today i'm
going to talk about
our recent work on uh nearly
mini max outmode some more complexity
for the
reward free reinforced learning
so this is a joint work with han jung
who is a
talented peer student from qinghai
university and
xian yang ji who is also from chiang mai
so usually in
reinforcement they talk about
interactive say final horizon mdp
so let's since this is a theoretical
reinforcement learning workshop let me
just
briefly review what it is so in this
setting we often
we can show an agent which is
interacting with an environment
at each time step the agent is at some
state and the agent will choose some
action
and based on the state the environment
move the agent to the next state
according to some transition function uh
let's say p and then the agent gets some
rewards
according to some reward function okay
and
for the final version mvp we will repeat
this
interaction for h times and
h here uh it's a planning poison or you
can call it absolutely
and we will repeat this game for several
times let's say k
episodes in total the goal of the agent
is to find a policy you can single
policy as a mapping from the state
to action so this
the goal is to find the policy and
maximize the volume function or maximize
the expected total rewards
of this form so since this is a you know
the transition is unknown so it is a
basic learning problem
so instead of finding the output policy
our goal is to find a new output policy
so here uh i want to find the absolute
optimum policy for some option
um from zero to one
and this output this policy is close to
the optimum one within absolute error
so here we start denotes the volume
function of the output policy
and v price or say a near-open cost
okay so this is a standard episodic
final horizon
setting so
um so let's talk i'll talk about the
free reinforcement
which is formalized um
in the student house paper this year so
basically when we interact
with the environment we don't get the
reward information
so the motivational thing is that in
many applications
rewards often defined or engineered by
the user afterwards
after the agent already collects the
data
and this reward may depend on the
collectively transform
so formally uh in the setting we have
two phases
the first one is called exploration
phase
uh the agent interacts with environment
and collects a data set let's call it d
so the inside is just the state action
in pairs
and um we have in total k episodes and
um h levels so h and k from one one to
big h k okay this is our data sets
and then based on this data set in the
planning phase the second phase
we are given an arbitrary word which may
depend on data as well
or even arbitrarily defined and we want
to compute a policy
such that it is close to the optimal one
uh that depends on this uh reward
uh based in absolute error okay
um and the question here is
how many samples or how many episodes
during the
exploration phase we need so that we can
have
this guarantee we can output in uh
policy pi so this is close to the
optimal one
within absolute okay so
um this is the setting
uh by the way if you have any questions
you can interrupt
or yeah shown the q a i guess
so uh let me leave some motivations here
um the first one
is uh batch reinforced learning
so um i think in this workshop and many
existing results show that
if the collective data set has a good
coverage
over the state space then we can compute
the near output policy
okay so um people have defined various
um good definition of coverage but
basically it's a high level idea you
have as long as you have a good coverage
you can compute the neural policy
so for reward free reinforcement it's
basically asking the question how to
collect such a data set
uh with a good coverage
okay so this is a data collection
problem
another motivating scenario is
constrained reinforcement
where we often engineer the reward
function
such that we can encourage the agent to
have some desired behavior
for example we have some safety
constraint or have safety guarantees
or something like that and this process
often well turn arrow
and usually we need to define several
reward functions to achieve this desired
behavior
so for this set uh or this problem we
don't want to
repeatedly interact with this
environment uh when we use the new
uh reward function so we want to have a
fixed data set
and we just want to try out different
word function on the same data set
so here this reward reinforcement is
very helpful
because we just need to collect a fixed
data set and it works for
arbitrary reward function
okay um
all right so uh so today i'll talk about
the theoretical
uh reward for reinforcement um often to
develop the theory the first setting we
can think of is a tabular
mdp so in this setting we have the
number of states
is finite and number of actions finite
and here we'll assume the
transition is homogeneous which means
that
the transition function p does not
depend on the
time step a small h okay so it's called
the homogeneous
transition function and there's also
another setting called inhomogeneous
transition function where transition p
can depend on
the level h small h
okay um and then
we need to put some regularity
assumption on the rewards
so here we need uh we assume the reward
is non-negative
for all levels also we assume the total
reward
is upper bounded by one so this is our
assumption
uh so let me spend one slide expanding
uh
this reward scaling assumption okay
so so first the philosophy here is that
the aphthong
which you also assume is belongs to zero
to one
measure the performance of a policy or
the
value relative to the total reward
okay so it's a relative volume
so in most reinforced learning
theoretical reinforcing papers people
assume the
word belongs to their to one
okay so here but if you assume um
this condition the total reward becomes
big h because you totally have
h levels uh but since we want to use
option as a relative measure uh to to
uh evaluate the policy or volume we need
to
rescale the optimum to a rescue
option up by an h factor so
that this apps new epson graph presents
the relative uh uh performance
okay uh so for some basic because we
want
for some basically we often assume that
absolute balance goes to 0.1
so
we need to scale down the reward by an
h factor so that absolute now becomes 0
to 1 and measures the relative
performance
so after this rescaling we have the
total reward now is bounded by one
so this is a raw scaling because now we
can just uh that absolutely belongs to
zero one itself
zero to big h
and however the problem is this
assumption
uh is a little bit weird because each
step is one
or it's upper boundary of one over h and
if h is large the first steps rewards
variatory time so instead
we can work a more general assumption of
it's called
boundary the total reward so basically
we assume that reward is non-negative
and the total reward sponsored by one
the benefit of this assumption compared
to this rescaled uniformly bonded
assumption
is that this assumption can model some
sparse spy key reward
like in some place the reward can be as
large as one
instead of in this assumption the
maximum reward is only one range
so um there's many discussion about the
rights towards scaling
i can check hasham's thesis or nan and
alex
uh quotes 2018 open problem
so in this paper uh we our algorithm
works for this most general assumption
the boundary total
word assumption and i'll state
the existing results in terms of either
the uniformly bounded reward
or the this more general one
okay up to now are there any questions
think you're good yeah you're good
uh all right so let me review
some existing results so all the
digitals are
uh in big o big omega notations and uh
we ignore the
logarithm factors for now and this
reward are
under the um three scaled uniformly
boundary assumptions such that total
rewards one by one
or the boundary total word that which is
bounding by one as well
the lower bond which is approved in
genetic house paper
in february this year
they show that the lower bond is a
square
a or epsilon squared okay
so basically um the construction of
lower bound uses a packing over
all the states transition state tuple
uh tuples so in total you have square a
um
like dimension so that you have square a
or epsilon squared
and you can construct a packing on this
um um this space so that you can get
this lower bound
okay this is a high level description of
the their construction of lower bond
uh now let me state the upper bond
so actually the very classical paper
uh our max in 2002
a small modification of that algorithm
you can already get
uh upper bound of uh this reward freedom
for smart
um and this analysis is also showing uh
this modification
and the corresponding analysis is also
shown in this genetics paper
uh basically for if you apply this uh r
max or zero on max which is the
multiplication
you can get um this kind of bond so
uh square a is tight but
the dependency on h is not tight you can
see here the lower bond does not have an
h
dependency also the abstrom
cube is not tight comparing to the lower
bond which is
epsilon okay
uh so in the senate house paper um
to give a new algorithm called rf rlx4
so this algorithm's uh some companies
significantly better
than this r max algorithm
so epsilon now is tight it's alpha
squared
and they significantly improve the
dependency on h as well
from h to the ace to the h to the third
okay um so i'll talk about the algorithm
uh
idea as well in the later slides so this
appeared
in february and later in june
um by kaufman at all they propose
new algorithm which is the modification
or extension of
the famous ucr algorithm
uh they further improved the dependency
on h2h
square and uh
one month later by the essentially the
same group of people but the
uh they have a new algorithm called rf
express uh the algorithm also works for
some other settings well
but applying to this setting they can
further improve an h factor so now
in their bond it's h as for a or epsilon
squared
so in their objectives i'm using very
normal exploration bonus
to achieve this bond
i would like to say that these two
papers also apply to the inhomogeneous
transition model where the transition
can depend
on the level and for that setting
this bond is actually tight however uh
for the
uh homogeneous transition model you can
now directly transform
this um uh bound to the homogeneous
model by
um forgot i want to have a tight bond
because you know for the
lower bound there's no age dependency
okay so
here's our work um so
which appears in this october so our new
algorithm is called sstp and
we achieve the r square a or epsilon
square
sample complexity which matches the
lower bound
okay i'll talk more about technical
details later
so let me spend one more slice on the
significance of our
results so uh we show that under this
general assumption that reward
is non-active total bond level one our
algorithm
is have two um two
components one is for some playing stage
sampling the one for
planning is called truncated planning we
can solve this problem
uh using square a or option square axles
in the exploration phase
so first um this matches the lower bond
of two logarithm factors and more
importantly
i think um the conceptual message that
the bond is
independent or almost independent of the
planning horizon age where all existing
previous result
has a polynomial dependency on the
planning horizon age
i would like to mention that this kind
of logarithm dependency on h bonds
also appeared in uh this year
with uh video rabbit with my uh
collaborators like wilson wong
lin young sham earlier this year and
recently we further improved to have a
better bond
so our result for the reward
reinforcement learning
also depend or rely on our recent
results for the standard
capital reinforcement which with
logarithm
dependency on the planning horizon okay
so for those who are interested you can
check
my talk at the ro series virtual seminar
uh last week all right so um these are
the main
results um is there any questions about
the results
from now i will talk about the technical
details
i think that's great okay uh
cool so the first um
our result released on this option which
is first
uh i think is first appeared in genetic
house paper
so the it's a very important notion
in uh reward reinforced reinforcement is
this maximum
um expected visitation count
so what is this so given a state action
pair
this notion is defined as the maximum
policy
as a policy that can maximize its
expected
uh number of visitations in an episode
okay so this number uh is from 0 to
h because at most you visiting as a pair
h times okay so the observation in their
paper is that
uh if in the data set for every state
action pair
we have say and q type times
uh lambda i say data points for this
state action pairs for this action pair
and this intuitive let's say some
polynomial of
s h and around optimum then we can
compute an
absolute optimal policy with any
uh or you must have an approximate mdp
server
some new uh dynamic programming kind of
uh so where you can
as long as you have this guarantee you
can use any empty
to computing your outcome policy um so
now that's in all the hearts
basically by some um some performance
difference lemma
and some perturbation analysis of the um
mdp
io propagation based on
this observation you can very easily uh
derive an algorithm uh so basically
the algorithm for the expression is just
for every set action pair
let's say we just sets reward
uh to be one for the selection pair and
all the others the action pairs to be
zero
and then during the exploration we just
run and
say standard hybrid reinforcement
learning algorithm uh
with this um like manually defined
reward
let's take it as a black box and began
and then this option will automatically
collect
as many data as possible for the state
action pair
and we repeat for all the state action
pairs
uh enough times then we have enough they
have to have this guarantees
okay so the idea is very easy it's how
they and how they get their bond
so our first improvement is the boring
um we have a tighter sub feature
condition for the data set
uh so what we can show is that if in the
data sets for every state action pair
uh we have again intuitive lambda i say
data
where here we can have a using a very
specified analysis we can show that in
tune
only into scale with s or epsilon
squared
so if i have this amount of data for uh
each state action pair then we can
compute
an optimum subwoofer policy uh but here
it's not for arbitrary uh planning
algorithm
uh here we use a very specified one it's
called optimistic planning algorithm
um which basically uh uses
some bursting bond in your planning for
those who are familiar with tamarind for
spring this is
a very important trick you know planning
uh the tight box
so um and we in our planning we also use
this kind of
uh bonus bond in estimating the
qualities
okay so using this specific
uh planning algorithm we can show that
as long as your dataset have this amount
of data
uh you can have and you can also add
some optimum policy
the question here is that this is not an
actionable uh we cannot transform uh
subject directly to an algorithm because
lambda here is an unknown quantity
right it depends on
the uh underlying environment uh which
is unknown to us
so how can do it so here
we use a another widely
uh a very popular trick uh doubling
to um discretize um
this lambda basically so we can use
this kind of layered um
analysis so we divide
the state action space
into several layers okay
so each set say x1 to xm
satisfy that each action pair in
this set satisfies its maximum
expected uh vegetation counts is
scales with h or two to the ice power
okay so it's kind of a layered uh
partition of the state action space
and in total we have only log h or
option
layers so using some similar analysis we
can show that
the sufficient set condition for data
sets that
for every state action pair uh in this
set uh as long as the number of data is
uh as h over two to the ice power
times epsilon square where here this
n acid id denotes the visiting cons or
number of visitations of the sa in this
collective data set
then we can output an uh a near optimal
policy
within absolute uh submarine of
optimality
okay so
this is a more actionable um item
because um
this is already a discrete value and we
can use it in our algorithm design
um so next step is through how to design
an algorithm to collect data set
sets that can satisfy this uh condition
so this is our main algorithm for
collecting
uh data so here
we first initialize
our starting uh say set
as the original set action space
and we have in total m iterations
um so first for each iteration will
maintain
a subset of the original state action
space say by i so each y represents that
we want to collect enough data that is
in this x i set where
remember x i a is the same actions
such that the maximum expected uh
between common skeletal is
uh h over two to the ice power
and um y is basically an empirical
approximation
to isi so
we want to for each say stage
i we want to collect data
in the x i um
action pairing xi as much as many as
possible
and so to for doing that we just set
the state action in that set to be one
and we're going to regret minimization
uh i'll say
type of algorithm for say n episodes
and the trickiest thing here is that for
each episode suppose for some city
action pair in this set we already
collected enough data
say sh over to the ice power epsilon
square
data points which means that if we have
this amount of data for a
particular selection pair it means i've
already collected enough data
in that case we just reset the uh reward
for this action pair to be there
and then uh when we finish one stage we
just
update the set uh we just maintain
all the state action such that uh the
number of visitation is smaller than
um sh or two to the ice power and atoms
were
okay and then we move to the next uh
stage
so this is a high level uh idea of our
algorithm
uh so in terms of analysis we need n to
be large enough
so that the algorithm guarantees collect
uh sh or two to the s power and alpha
square some poles
if does this state action pair maximize
uh maximum
maximum mesitation expectation in common
is bigger than say
h over two t is power okay um
so in this regard minimization algorithm
will choose our recent
which is state-of-the-art algorithm
which have this kind of regret bond
which is sufficient for our purpose
and another tricky thing is here we
recite reward at some point so we need a
new analysis for a reward worrying
uh our regret uh regret bond
so combining all of this we can show
that uh number episode
per stage is only a square a or
epsilon squared in total we have you
know m is only a logarithm factor
so in total the number of complexity uh
the
data we have is square a or epsilon
squared
so this is how we prove our sample
complexity
uh so in conclusion we have a new
algorithm for reward free reinforced
learning
uh which uh nearly matches lower bound
absolute opposing factors
and important is independence of the
planning portion h
so uh the natural next question is to
study the large state space
or the function approximation setting
where we don't want our summer company
depends on the number of states
so there are some existing works for
example we can assume
the observations or the observable
states are generated according to
a small number of hidden states uh so we
have one work
and uh mr have a read more recent work
there are both from system variables
from microsoft
research and another setting studies at
reinforced learning with linear function
approximation either assuming the
transition or some policy is linear in
some sense
and emma has a very uh
good paper on this setting they proved
that understanding assumption
um the number of uh some posts does not
need to scale this is
uh states number of states but only
needs to scale with the
feature damage and we have a similar
result
um but with a different assumption but
also for linear function approximation
and both paper appear in this year's
ribs
so that's all i want to talk about i
would like to conclude here and
maybe take some questions great and we
have a
couple of minutes for questions uh i
don't see anything new in q a
um
all right yeah um hi hi simon nice talk
and i have a quick question that i um
previously have just typed into the chat
so so let me uh let me say it again
so so i can see the motivation of uh
allowing the reward choice to actually
depend on data because it makes the
algorithm more general
but i'm wondering like suppose you have
a reward that's fixed but hidden from
the
um from from the agent at the
exploration phase
like when considering i think the
setting with a fixed reward
distribution that's independent to the
data like it's also a reasonable and
interesting setting
and potentially you can knock off a
factor of s like do you guys
have you guys consider that problem and
uh what what makes it hard if you guys
haven't
um and yeah i'm just curious the
reasons question uh actually there's a
paper i know by john at all
this year they call it task agnostic
uh reinforcement basically you don't
know the reward
before you collect data so they can show
an
s a or epsilon square times some polyh
factors
uh so yeah i mean uh definitely you can
get rid of
the s factor there um but the dependency
on
h is still unclear yeah i
actually think that if you if you
combine um
like your exploration um phase and
all the data that you collected with uh
the results that the uniform conversions
result i presented on tuesday i think
you can you can
you can already get that as a corollary
but i need to think more carefully about
it
yeah the dependency there is a little
bit tricky because here
our basically learns the transition
function within
a one norm that basically requires
a s escort uh
but here you did have some long time
some independence
between the reward and the transactions
yeah yeah you have to somehow
use independence to collapse that that
inner product so that you
you don't suffer that yeah best i don't
think it's trivial but yeah i would like
to talk about
later all right thanks for asking okay
well thank you very much for the great
talk
um i think we'll move on to our final
speaker now
um is ming d here or